[Music]
remember 2016 Italy's populist
opposition is shaking off the
establishment
you're in control pending design the vs
nope it's my truckle-bed we're on the
Hoffman crew Georgian Bonzo
Hey
their days away from a referendum that
could spell the end for the Italian
government and make it the latest Domino
in the toppling international order
around the world populist leaders are
connecting with voters fed up with
politics as usual and exploiting anger
as an establishment out of touch with
ordinary people but giving voice to
people's frustrations is one thing
offering them real answers is quite
another
[Music]
[Applause]
Jeff Segal grew up in New York but moved
to Italy 40 years ago
Yanina savage Jesus commanded America
Philip Roth he's trying to drum up
support ahead of the referendum if it's
ever chooses a little mini molecule of
the nebulas life no no no no no my
family no people and you have to focus
now myeloma we still get into this
thanks for suing the problem is here the
people who will obtain they won't even
go and vote and nullify the both of you
just won't show up this egg don't trust
politicians anymore thank you dishonest
politician disappointing Dunfield
amounts like millions of Italian voters
jeff has turned his back on mainstream
political parties in our campaigns for
the populist five star movement its
sought to build a following less through
policies and more by challenging
everything about italy's political class
known a man one journal would make every
TV format dos semanas she burst and okay
looper boy under there yes we want to
make Italy a better place to live and
work but the way things are set up now
is not to constructive where's were
victims I think every Italian citizen is
a victim step to cook the politicians
five stars anti-establishment message is
resonating with voters
it is now Italy's biggest opposition
party the country has been crippled by
recession and stagnating wages The
Grapes of inequality among the highest
in Europe many people feel left behind
by globalization and let down by
political leaders now the populist sense
there may be an opportunity to bring
those leaders down
a referendum on constitutional reform
has become a vote of confidence in the
ruling India
Prime Minister Matteo Renzi has said he
will resign at the country vote - no no
enough inside you who live there he's
the latest mainstream politician to find
himself in the firing line
[Music]
tonight thousands of five-star
supporters are gathering at a rally in
Turin some are starting to ask what they
might do with success people want to
hear what we have to say you can't just
be in the opposition inept isn't
positive saying things that we say we
want to do for the people for the
citizens to change things then you have
to do
we study for knowing each other no
Virginia Raji is one of the first
leaders of five-star to win power at the
new mayor of Rome she's already under
pressure to offer actual solution I'm
gonna make a noise GMO very no no no no
GMO appearing via Santa Claus India Red
Delicious adenine for cielos blue pony
product even crazy Ferrari Italia fuel
available Sony geometry improvisation
ability a linear cheering hola me llamo
chrome check over mark but Raji is just
a warm-up act there's one man that
everyone has turned out to see five
stars leader and showman that a greener
former stand-up comedian Grillo knows
the button is depressed it appeals to
people with emotions that it helped turn
five star into a real sort when looking
the more it wonder he can't defeat
Dubois he on the so called Casa
premeditation file for say stuff we
don't we take the free air Laura hello
let a Grillo has vowed to get rid of
political parties but he certainly knows
how to start one
Willard success has come through
impassioned charges against the corrupt
elite and global forties he blamed the
Italy's world but five stars leaders may
soon have a harder note to hear a
question of how they would tackle
unemployment and inequality
two days after the rally Italians
overwhelmingly voted no in the
referendum Prime Minister Renzi made
good on his promise to stand out
it's another victory for populism as
across the world charismatic leaders
defy expectations they're finding
success selling deceptively simple
answers to difficult questions our
country is going to start building and
making things again America hurt again
America first they almost always blame
the failings of free trade and mass
migration for rising inequality but is
this the right target
[Music]
he cities are immune to the unease and
impact of globalization here in San
Francisco is another more conspicuous
driver of change it's not just trade
that's transforming the global economic
order it's technology
the latest venture from a San Francisco
startup as the potential to turn one of
America's most iconic industries on its
head
last year uber paid 680 million dollars
for auto a company whose technology
could fundamentally change trucking
forever it allowed the truck to drive
down a highway with nobody at the wheel
the company claimed it could save the
industry billions of dollars a year
reduce emissions by a third and
eliminate the driver errors that caused
up to 87% of truck crashes this bright
sounding future has a dark side
[Music]
a series of studies have found
technology not globalization to be the
biggest driver of inequality in
developed countries
there were three and a half million
people employed in trucking in America
with their industry seemingly the next
in line for automation many faced an
uncertain future
Robert Calista has driven trucks since
the 1980s both his parents were truck
drivers before him this job has said my
family skipped roof over my family the
whole time I drove it's my home on home
this is Peter Belt and he was named
after a truck called Peter vote
you look at California they're tasted so
many of us companies out here not just
cooking companies manufacturing
companies small business people they're
running us out of the state
[Music]
you know I deliver in Silicon Valley to
several of the big computer companies
they're just more educated they're there
for themselves they want the money they
don't want us I've voted for Trump
because I wanted to change basically to
tell the country well California New
York we're sorry but you don't suppose
country
populist leaders have been able to
capitalize on a growing sense of them
and us as inequality grows in Western
democracies wealthy California has
become one of the most economically
unequal states in America as technology
has displaced many lower skilled jobs
Russell Hancock runs a think-tank in
Silicon Valley sponsored by some of the
state's biggest tech companies in recent
years something has changed Silicon
Valley companies used to be heroes
superheroes even now the Binks cast is
villain in this story Silicon Valley is
starting to be painted with the same
kind of paint that's been painted on
Wall Street for example people are
wondering why Silicon Valley's companies
are doing more to address poverty and to
address the income inequality in our
region an alienated public turned on the
establishment because it failed to
provide answers
as some tech giants become as powerful
as that establishment it's a lesson
they're starting to learn so they're
going back to school if technological
change is part of the problem the people
behind it are asking how they can offer
solutions you've probably heard about
self-driving cars because we live in San
Francisco
they're already people building
self-driving trucks which means three
million truck drivers are going to be
out of work
paddy-paw toby is the CEO of code.org
backed by some of Silicon Valley's
biggest firms he campaigns to children
to be taught computer science in schools
truck driving is just one example of
types of work they're going to get
replaced by computers and software we've
all learned in the last few months
whether it's Americans with the election
or whether it's in the UK with the
brexit or really worldwide there's
really an angst about opportunity people
around the world want opportunity they
want the idea that if you work hard the
system will reward you so the real
question is how do we bring opportunity
back if you think about our education
system at all ages we're not preparing
today's kids for what the jobs of the
future are going to be we're not even in
a situation to prepare today's adults
for the jobs of the future
technology is changing all around us so
as adults we need to be lifelong
learners it's something that can start
in high school or even in elementary or
middle school continue to University and
then the hardest part is setting up
programs to retrain today's adults as
they find that they want to get into a
better job or if they lose their job due
to automation it will need help from
governments and business to ensure
retraining isn't an option reserved for
those with the time and resources
technology itself can help too
Sebastian Thrun used to be in charge of
Google's self-driving car project now he
runs an education company offering quick
training programs online on the past one
irritation was sufficient for the
lifetime and your search shop usually
was the last drop today the typical
dropped in the United States is lesson
five yes technology on top of it is
moving faster than ever before
so whatever education you have is
outdated faster and to make matters
worse we lived on earth but we should
provide for the people in the world is
an indication that keeps them current
they can be employable
an ongoing online education could be one
way to start relieving the pressure on
people who today feel left behind
because in the long run technology has
the potential to create more jobs than
it destroys we had about 300 years of
crazy technology development already
that transformed jobs some people fear
change
now obviously change speeds uncertainty
what my job can look like is my persons
of being secure in the future I would
love to engrave with people who bring a
positive attitude because it's always
gotten behind
too many people in western democracies
progress is still something that happens
to other people
wealth does not spread itself an
underclass appears beyond him finding a
way to reconnect with them and provide
an alternative to populism will be at
the top of the agenda for the political
and business leaders of tomorrow
you